Let's go back to the phone is at (617) 830-4750.
And see what is on the minds of folks who
are
calling in today, starting with our color
from the three zero one area code. Who's calling
from three zero one today.
Hi, this is Johnny. Hey John. Hey David. I
have a question in a comment and my comment
is, uh, you know, I'm from DC and I really
avoid any, uh, superfluid political analysis,
but I really enjoy your show and I just started
listening like maybe a week or so ago. Thank
you. Uh, so I appreciate your take on things.
I appreciate that. Yeah. And so my question
is, um, with the impeachment scandal, um,
if we could sort of zoom out for a second
and look at a larger picture of how the U
S bargains, uh, with foreign countries in
terms of aid. So I actually work in the divest
or relief industry in aid. So my question
is what are your takes on how aid needs to
change, uh, abroad and how we, how we engage
with other countries and foreign powers.
This is a big topic. So you have number one,
you have aid that then is given with the explicit
or implicit condition that the money is spent
back in the United States on weapons. So this
is the case like with Saudi Arabia, some of
the aid to Israel and there's other countries.
So that is something that one side argues
is great for the economy because we're, we're
giving aid
and then it's [inaudible]
coming right back and supporting jobs and
whatnot. But it's a pretty corrupt and ugly
reality. And that's, that's one type of aid
that is problematic. Another type of aid that
is problematic is aid where you are not really
helping the country to, um, I'm trying to
use the right words here. You're, you're giving
aid in a way that serves as a bandaid rather
than treating the problem, so to speak. So
I've talked before about how there's lots
of aid that, for example, goes to some place
and provides eyeglasses and shoes for people
or something like that. But if you don't actually
help the country establish infrastructure
where they can have eye doctors that are treating
people and they can get shoes without them
having to be handed over or whatever the case
may be, it's really only a bandaid. It's not
a longterm solution. So I mean, th th there's
so many different ways that this needs to
be tackled and changed.
Okay. Right. So, um, well just I guess in,
in, in terms of how the impeachment and AU
has raised awareness about how, like you said,
ugly, the ADE transactional relationship,
uh, between foreign power looks. How do you
think, um, in the future, uh, things are going
to change knowing that Republicans and Democrats
alike, um, have been very generous for other
aid giving activities that don't include weapons
that don't include, uh, like you said, these,
you know, one stop shop where we're basically
American products that are sold in foreign
countries using a government budget. Um, how
do you think that conversation's going to
be changed? Uh, moving forward? W whatever
the outcome of the impeachment.
I, I mean, you're talking because the impeachment
hearings are over the quid pro quo, bribery
use whatever word you want relating to the
military aid and the smearing of Biden. You
mean how will that change aid in the future?
Correct.
Yeah. I don't know that it will actually,
I mean, so you're, you're certainly going
to have some defenders of Trump who say, listen,
we negotiate all the time. We don't just give
aid. We give it in exchange for the money
being spent in the us or we give it in exchange
for this or that. The, the key, of course
that's very disingenuous because here it's
a president doing it for a very specific
personal [inaudible]
the benefit, which has, he wants a better
shot at defeating Joe Biden if that's who
he ends up running against in 2020. So you'll
have Republicans who will make that argument.
But big picture, I mean, we don't tend to
learn for these really big things like campaign
finance, foreign aid,
ah,
the corporatocracy. We tend to not really
to learn from things when they go wrong. So
I have no expectation that anything's going
to change really.
Okay. Thanks for your perspective, David.
Yup. All right. Thank you for the call. I
appreciate it.